well for about a year we know many of
you have been out of work due to losing
your job but tonight there's a lot of
hope if you're searching for work we
thank you for joining us
at six i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez several
valley companies are looking to fill
positions right away
joe moeller is live at the strat where
one hiring event was today and joe it
seems like
it's like warped speed now over the past
month the plan is to be 100 percent open
and they're stepping up for it
and it feels like it just gets getting
busier and busier and we are getting a
lot of
job announcements for job fairs
happening across the valley and that's
not including all the help wanted signs
we're also seeing out there when you
just travel around town now take a look
we're at the valet area here at the
stratton you can just see
how busy it is here on this thursday uh
the vice president tells us
that they are now reaching near capacity
on the weekends
as more people come to las vegas more
companies like the strat are needing to
hire
more workers my interview went great and
i got the job
jocelyn lomovita is now one of the
newest front desk receptionist at the
strat
i wasn't really expecting anything my
mom had told me about it she sent me
like a screenshot from the news
she was one of many who came here for a
job fair we're hiring everything we're
guest room attendants
we have vip services representatives
front desk we have supervisor positions
as more people travel more companies are
needing help strat vice president
stephen thayer says
they want to get people back to work so
exciting to be able to offer jobs to
people and bring them back on
we're of course welcoming back all of
our former employees and now we need
more on top of that so it's just a great
feeling
the strat isn't the only place looking
to fill positions the 8 news now
newsroom was flooded with notices about
hiring events
boyd gaming mcdonald's ellis island and
a number of other places are looking for
help
even government jobs are out there the
city of north las vegas needs more
people for seasonal jobs as summer
approaches
you're starting to see a little bit of a
sense of normalcy there's excitement
that these opportunities are out there
and it's exciting for us to see that
businesses are reopening we're seeing
that
you know it's not just city jobs that
are coming back but everywhere else as
well
the job fairs announcements continue to
come in we put together a simple easy to
find list on the 8 news now website for
all the upcoming events
my interview is really good yeah it
feels good
it feels really good
now back out here live you're taking a
look at the valet section here at the
strat where it's
getting busy out here now uh coming
moving forward we do expect to see even
more people out there looking for jobs
as the
job search requirement is being added on
to the
unemployment uh requirements for people
moving forward for benefits so we do
expect to see more people
out there looking for jobs but there's
definitely places like the strat looking
to hire more people i'll send it back to
you
joe i think it was uh i think with sally
jaramillo had a report a couple of weeks
ago with a local restaurant saying
they were having trouble finding people
to apply for jobs uh what
what were you finding today with some of
these job fairs
well we went to a number of places today
and it was a steady flow of people going
inside to try to apply for jobs but we
tried to actually head over to ellis
island to see what the job fair was like
there but they said they were too busy
to even have us there so
you can tell there are people out there
definitely looking to get a job and i
just expect that
to pick up here in the next next few
weeks promising signs all right joe
moeller thanks so much for that tonight
and for a full list of the companies
that are hiring in the valley and it's a
long one
you can head to 8newsnow.com and click
on the job board tab
we have put together a list and also
links to apply directly